a very real threat of coronavirus the
first British victim a diamond Princess
cruise passenger was announced at the
same time as three new cases in the UK
to patients in England who'd recently
returned from Iran and the first
recorded case in Wales a traveller back
from northern Italy we are expecting to
see more cases there's very little doubt
now that we will see that that's
happening in other parts of the world
our challenge now is to get the NHS
ready prepared to be able to deal with
the consequences of that frontline
critical care doctors those who treat
the sickest patients say they're not
ready they say the NHS is already a
breaking point and a surgeon covered 19
cases would [ __ ] the Health Service
my main concern is going forward are we
going to be able to accommodate a influx
of patients should tomorrow the
situation get worse so we already know
that we're about capacity and a lot of
units are saying that we're cancelling
patients anyway add on top of our new
patients they're coming in we'll find
that we're in a position where we're not
able to accommodate them there are
currently just over 4,000 critical care
beds available in England to allow for a
rise in demand a critical care unit
should be no more than 85% full in
December they were just over 75% full
which is okay but looking under the
surface of that figure reveals a
different picture a quarter of trusts in
England had 85 percent or more of their
beds in use and 11 NHS trusts had every
single bed in use the winter pressures
means some elective operations have
already been cancelled but if there's a
large outbreak of coronavirus more
difficult choices will have to be made
what people will be working very hard at
now is trying to make sure that no
urgent treatments cancer treatments for
example get delayed but of course there
are going to be knock-on consequences
the Department of Health and Social Care
told us they expect the virus to have
some impact on the UK
our planning for any eventuality doctors
make life-and-death choices all the time
but if covert 19 spreads in this country
they may be forced to make those
decisions more frequently
Ashish Joshi Sky News